[Musique]
dans les sinistres bâtiment des femmes
les prisonnières d'or entassés sur des
couchettes superposées
où
bah
dans un réveiller se lève lentement
oh
il marche vers la fenêtre entrouverte et
louvre complètement
bouleversé le regard perdu dans un rêve
tragique et les coûts
[Musique]
des larmes en plissés boussieux fondre
de l'autre côté du camp debout près du
phonographe widow souris pour ne pas
pleurer
oh
le petit garçon sort rejoigne son
meilleur dans la clean et saute dans ses
bras
[Musique]
via un épais brouillard envahi le camp
désert widow porte l'enfant endormi
je me suis peut-être perdu je suis
tudor c'est bientôt record qui a fait un
beau rêve vous n'êtes que tout ça n'est
qu'un rêve de toute façon
on est en train de rêver
demain matin maman vient de nous
réveiller elle nous prépare à deux bêtes
tasse de café au lait avec épices quand
on commencera pas mangé depuis je lui
ferais l'amour deux ou trois fois
j'y arrive il avance et s'enfonce dans
le brouillard
[Musique]
horrifié il s'arrête
des centaines de corps sont entassés
dans une fosse
il recule dépôt vente devant ce charnier
j'ai été très étonné j'allais vous poser
la question ce programme va être diffusé
en audiodescription qui c'est qui
connaît l'audiodescription mais vous
êtes pratiquement 70% donc
d'habitude les gens ne savent pas ce que
c'est et en fait audio description audio
écoutez écoutez quoi une description en
fait l'histoire commencé par une amitié
de deux petits garçons américain un
aveugle et son ami grégory qui ne
l'étaient pas et qui lui décrivait tous
les cols la récréation les petits
copains
les professeurs les sorties ils
écrivaient les paysages les costumes
fait tout ils ne se quittaient pas
grégory est devenu professeur et de ceux
de cette expérience il a élaboré une
théorie dont il a fait sa thèse et il a
présenté son sujet de thèse à ou doyens
de la school of creative arts de san
francisco qui était august coppola
august coppola le frère du réalisateur
francis ford coppola deux sets de ce
travail commun ils ont construit ils ont
créé un cursus de formation pour
vraiment former des descripteurs et pour
que le procédé qui l'ont appelée en
audiovision que moi j'ai préféré
traduire par audiodescription puisse se
diffuser aux etats unis non seulement
pour le cinéma mais aussi pour le
théâtre et pour tout type de spectacle
ce ce procédé vous allez voir m'a
passionné ça a été pour moi virage une
passion un jour soit un coup de
téléphone d'auguste coppola pour qui
j'avais fait déjà des traductions et qui
me dit marie 26 manager vous êtes
toujours traductrice ligne vous
vous enseignez vous êtes professeur
alesi qui comme super d'interprètes et
de traducteurs à la sorbonne
oui le cinéma pour les aveugles
ça vous intéresse j'hésite un peu
surprise c'est pas le genre de
plaisanteries de l'auguste coppola il
enchaîne voilà vous allez venir à san
francisco suivre un cours de formation
sur l'audio description parce que je
veux que la france que j'adore soit le
premier pays d'europe à le diffuser et à
l'enseigné vous viendriez avec deux
étudiants nous allons les testée
auparavant dans choisira deux et vous
vient vincent francisco suivre la
formation
vous avez 24 heures pour me dire oui
j'ai dit oui j'ai dit oui et je suis
parti je suis parti avec deux étudiants
en études en architecture
monfils qui avait été sélectionné et une
étudiante en master d'anglais
une fois là bas le séminaire a été
orchestrée animé par gregory treasure on
nous a d'abord familiariser avec le
domaine de le monde des aveugles monde
des aveugles ou que j'ignorais et la
cécité chez les aveugles est compensée
par les quatre autres sens
c'est ce qu'on appelle le phénomène de
vie car ayant ensuite nous avons
travaillé sur deux extraits absolument
mythique du cinéma français l'extrait de
la scène du mime des enfants du paradis
qui totalement muette et qu'on ne peut
pas comprendre quand on ne voit rien et
les pilotes des diaboliques
d'henri-georges clouzot qui fait les
pieds la faim qui révèle le suspense
absolument haletant du film dans les
enfants du paradis s'agissait de décrire
le vol de la montre gousset et vous
devriez revoir ce film nine est une
merveille le mall de la montre gousset
par un pickpocket et ce en lui en le
mimant
baptiste jean louis barrault disculpe
garance arletty qui était accusé du vol
ce ces deux extraits ont été présentés
au festival de cannes en 1989 et
l'audiodescription a reçu vraiment à un
accueil absolument enthousiastes
le premier le fut le premier film que
nous avons fait après c'était indiana
jones et la dernière croisade et ce film
a aussi reçu un accueil enthousiaste
comme les autres le relais a été assurée
par la cense l'association valentin haüy
qui a permis qui a vraiment pris en
charge la diffusion des premiers films
et qui a joué un grand rôle dans le
développement de ce procédé
en fait le concept paraît simple au
départ il faut décrire c'est à dire
verbaliser le message visuel alors
décrire les actions les les expressions
décrire les costumes les lieux les
décors va tout ce qui n'est pas
accessible par les dialogues tout ce qui
n'est pas dit par les diables c'est
difficile parce que c'est un travail sur
la langue avec beaucoup de précision
beaucoup de rigueur
j'y reviendrai plus tard nous allons
faire une petite expérience
fermez les yeux allaient fermer les yeux
vous allez voir une scène de crime dans
une ruelle obscure et déserte deux
hommes se battent
l'un d'eux le plus jeune sort un couteau
et le plonge dans le ventre de l'autre
qui s'écroulent les mains pleines de
sang
il s'enfuit en courant vous avez vu
entendu les mots clés et vous avez ça a
provoqué chez vous
une représentation mentale c'est ça
c'est une forme de traduction et vous
allez voir venir tentera du christ moi
qui traduit de texte à texte un texte en
langue étrangère que j'interprète dans
une autre jeu j'ai fait ce parallèle
entre le message visuel qui n'est pas
verbal et son interprétation dans un
texte descriptif le descripteur que j'ai
appelé aussi traducteur d'image est un
passeur de sens
la méthode est très rigoureuse
pourquoi pourquoi et l'amoureuse parce
que on ne peut pas faire de
l'amateurisme on ne peut pas faire de
l'improvisation
on travaille on travaille sur la langue
sur les richesses syntaxique sur les
richesse sémantique c'est une
c'est une obligation absolue d'abord il
y a quatre étapes à respecter
la première étape consiste à visionner
le film pour s'en imprégner
comme on dit en traduction se
l'approprient on se l'approprient pour
comprendre l'esprit du film le vouloir
dire du réalisateur quand on rencontre
c'est encore bien mieux pour identifier
tous les personnages pour hiérarchiser
les éléments à décrire dans la qui sont
importants d'autres pas et ça c'est
vraiment le problème la première étape
la deuxième c'est de faire de la
recherche documentaire
pourquoi la recherche documentaire parce
que on le mot doit être le mot juste
le contexte historique géographique
politique sociale doit aussi être
évoquée pour les mails et les terres n'a
le lexique par exemple un revolver n'est
pas un pistolet une robe à panier n'est
pas une robe à crinoline
de la soie du brocard n'est pas du crêpe
georgette enfin je caricature mais il
faut être exigeant sur la qualité du
lexique de la troisième étape au sista
débusquer les implicites et réalisateur
adore d un fils dans un éléphant ça
trompe énormément anny duperey passe au
dessus d'une grille d'aération et sa
robe se soulève
exactement comme la robe de marilyn
monroe dans sept ans de réflexion
ça c'est le clin d'oeil du réalisateur
et s'il implicite qui va falloir évoqué
comme on le peut et avec le discours
approprié
donc ça c'est encore une des étapes et
la dernière étape c'est la musique
nous avons vu avec double cadence et
j'ai adoré cette adéquation entre
l'image et la musique du film
cette musique elle est composée pour le
film pour servir même message pour
provoquer l'émotion
vous imaginez il était une fois dans
l'ouest sans musique
les james bond
la boum ou pretty woman
bon donc vous vois sourire et c'est
vraiment important parce que vous vous
rendez compte que la musique aussi doit
être prise en compte et alors cette
musique elle laisse une respiration
puisque parfois l'aveuglent est saturé
d'informations et ça lui permet de
souffler un petit peu c'est seulement
quand même fait respecter toutes ces
étapes que l'on peut écrire le film le
le texte descriptif on peut recommencer
à décrire le fil ce travail d'écriture
je voulais dit c'est un travail sur la
langue extrêmement exigeant il faut
mobiliser tout son bagage cognitifs et
linguistique
mais il ya deux contraintes alors deux
contraintes absolument incontournable la
première c'est la contrainte de temps
parce que la description doit être
incrustée entre les dialogues des films
sinon ce sera une véritable cacophonie
donc parfois on a très peu de temps
si on a très peu de temps on met un
style télégraphique si on a beaucoup
plus de temps on peut faire de la poésie
comme dans out of africa où je me suis
régalé à à décrire les flamands roses et
la lumière qui scintille sur le lac avec
les troupeaux de gnous bon donc
cela dit il ya aussi une deuxième
contrainte la deuxième contrainte c'est
l'objectivité
pourquoi l'objectivité parce que des
scripteurs est tentée il y ait un danger
il est il peut laquelle peut juger
il peut imposer ses propres émotions
alors que c'est tout le contraire il
faut faire il faut provoquer chez le
destinateur elle destinataire aveugle
les émotions ses propres émotions en
fonction de sa sensibilité en fonction
de ses goûts et en fonction de son
bagage punitif bon tout cela vraiment et
passionnant vous voyez ma passion et je
l' ai transmises à mes étudiants parce
que il faut être formé pour être audio
descripteur il faut être formé et j'ai
eu la chance dans mon université de
créer une formation d'audio descripteur
pour assurer la relève et à lyon 2 pour
former aussi des audio descripteur et
dea dess dea des guides aussi des guides
des scripteurs dans une section qui
s'appelait sciences du langage médiateur
culturel voilà parce que cette
description on peut tout décrire donc on
peut aussi l'appliquer pour les musées
pour les visites pour l'événement pour
les événements pour tout même le feu
d'artifice et feu d'artifice du 14
juillet pourquoi pas
c'est plus difficile voilà donc cette
formation elle a débouché sur les
descripteurs que qui vont j'espère avoir
du travail
pourquoi parce que la prise en compte du
handicap visuel a obligé les chaînes de
télévision à des quotas de programmes
audiodécrits les premières chaînes qui
ont été partie prenante c'est arte et
tf1 est actuellement vous avez tous
puisque vous avez entendu parler
d'audiodescription vous avez tous vu
cette phrase
ce programme sera diffusé dans la
description est de plus en plus ça s'est
multiplié
ma crainte c'est que par souci
d'économie des budgets réduits la
qualité en soufre puisse oser sacrifier
à la qualité
c'est vraiment un grand danger et ce
serait tout à fait dommage alors quand
on pense quand on pense que j'ai décrit
enfin nous avons décrit mon fils et moi
45 films plus c'était pièce de théâtre
je vais vous donner quelques exemples de
difficulté après tout cela d'abord une
des difficultés ça a été dans la folie
des grandeurs ou la scène du bain et la
scène les aveugles hollandais que de
devoir parce qu'ils utilisent le mot
voir un film de de funès ce que tout le
monde riez et pas eu donc la scène du
bain consisté à décrire le blay blaze
qui rentrent l'extrémité d'une serviette
de toilette dans une oreille pour la
sortir dans l'autre et faire coulisser
la serviette et on entend des zooms
comprendre ça c'était pour vraiment le
le verbaliser ça a été du travail
deuxième deuxième extrait dans cyrano de
bergerac un problème de niveau de langue
cyrano veut voir roxane tout seul et il
veut écarter la dame de compagnie qui
est très gourmand il hume et des gâteaux
chercher dans la boutique de ragueneau
les gâteaux dans un corner et ils lui
donnent les gâteaux il lui offre légale
ou non il lui remet les gâteaux il lui
flanque les gâteaux et voyez
l'adéquation du niveau de langue entre
la fidélité du geste et le terme
approprié le terme qui a été choisi et
il lui flanque c'est vraiment ça et on
se met en situation
une autre difficulté c'est le cinquième
élément ou la transformation de cette
espèce de masse plastique dans une sorte
de bloc opératoire a consisté à faire
émerger une créature sublime doué d'une
force surnaturelle et ça je vous dis
c'est un temps infini l'autre l'autre
une autre un autre exemple vous voulez
vous donner c'est out of africa et out
of africa avec la musique de mozart et
toute cette qualité de l'image est ce
déploiement
cette exubérance de la végétation des
animaux et provoqué l'émotion et cette
émotion je vous donnais une anecdote
personnelle c'est qu'en sortant de la
projection une aveugle m'a dit madame
j'ai pleuré c'était tellement beau et là
on se dit j'ai atteint mon j'ai atteint
mon but donc voilà c'est sont des
expériences fantastiques jeu j'espère
qu'ils vont continuer et perdurer et se
développer de plus en plus ce qui est
beaucoup de travail
il ya beaucoup de travail à faire
surtout pour pour faire en sorte que les
gens prennent conscience et qui sacrifie
lieux donne l'argent nécessaire pour le
faire ils sont ne coûte pas cher du tout
une audio description dans un budget de
films c'est une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan
alors quand on pense au début à cette
histoire de deux petits américains
keynes sont inséparables et vous les
imaginez un soir installé dans un canapé
et lun grégory décrivant à l'autre le
train sifflera trois fois le beau
western et bien ça vous voyez ça c'est
c'est fantastique et on est tenté de
citer saint-exupéry on ne voit bien
qu'avec le coeur
[Applaudissements]